[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
hola un gusto estar aquí si ustedes me
preguntan que soy pues soy química pero
normalmente a esta pregunta les siguen
otras
eres ingeniera química química
farmacéutica bioquímica que eres y
realidad no soy nada de eso soy de
ciencias químicas
soy científica y la verdad el ser
científica es algo que siempre he
querido porque ciencia la ciencia es
creativa es innovadora te ayuda a
entender la naturaleza por ejemplo y a
partir de eso puedes aportar a la
sociedad puedes descubrir nuevas drogas
para el cáncer la diabetes es excelente
es apasionante
no es nada aburrida pero es un largo
camino y hacer ciencia en bolivia pues
no suena muy bien desde principio pero
la idea es decirles si se puede
en realidad he tenido la oportunidad
primero de entrar a la carrera de
ciencias químicas le ha hecho a la
carrera literalmente a los 21 años ya
era de ciencias químicas ya tenía mi
licenciatura y todo eso pero
no me creía capaz todavía de generar
proyectos grandes ideas que consigan
buenos financiamientos y hacer ciencia
entonces qué hacer tampoco había la
posibilidad de salir al mercado y
conseguir un buen trabajo en un
laboratorio no o sea no es un campo así
muy comercial el asunto entonces
conseguí una beca a españa pero me costó
irme estaba muy bien aquí tenía amigos
tenía un novio entonces eso a veces
cuesta cuesta separarse de todo esto y
ir adelante pero tomé la decisión de
irme y hacer lo que más me gustaba
realmente trabajar en laboratorios y
tratar de descubrir cosas nuevas pero en
españa'
yo estudié lo que ellos querían que
estudie no lo que yo quería estudiar
aprendí muchísimo por supuesto pero no
lo que yo específicamente quería y
además quería ver vivir en bolivia
entonces cuando terminé mis estudios en
españa rne a bolivia a ver qué hago y
ahí entonces surgió la idea de bueno a
ver qué oportunidades tenemos en bolivia
tenemos una gran biodiversidad vegetal
por ejemplo y entonces surgió la idea de
entrar al campo de los productos
fitoterápicos fito significa planta un
producto fitoterápico es un producto
terapéutico a partir de una planta y
puede ser desde un mate de manzanilla
eso ya es un producto fitoterápico un
jarabe de huir a oirá o lo que sea pero
tiene que ser un producto que tenga un
control de calidad basado en ciencia y
tecnología eso eso es lo que al final
realmente genera grandes ingresos genera
las cosas bien entonces
primero les quiero explicar por qué
estudiar el desarrollo de productos
fitoterápicos en bolivia
los medicamentos que se generan y entran
en farmacias necesitan un largo tiempo
de estudio de 15 a 20 años y millones de
dólares de inversión 1300 millones de
dólares hasta 2000 millones de dólares o
sea es y si no es un campo en el que es
muy difícil competir a nivel mundial
entonces no no podemos entrar lo que si
pasa es que últimamente ha habido muy
alta inversión y pocos resultados
entonces
en general toda la sociedad ha decidido
fijarse en otras cosas no solamente en
descubrir compuestos que tengan una
actividad que puedan ser parte de un
medicamento y ahí está el tema de fito
terápicos que tienen como principio
activo un extracto una mezcla de
compuestos no son un compuesto ya y eso
por qué porque en realidad las plantas
en sí mismas ya tienen propiedades han
sido utilizadas desde siempre plantas
medicinales el 80 por ciento de la
población mundial las utiliza y en
bolivia las utilizan muchísimo muchísimo
y la organización mundial de la salud ha
reconocido esto y dice pues no tenemos
que estudiar solamente compuestos sino
también extractos plantas en su conjunto
pero siempre con calidad seguridad y
eficacia en base a investigación
en bolivia tenemos grandes oportunidades
en este sentido primero porque los
países del norte tienen poca
biodiversidad vegetal y todas las
plantas que existen ahí y ha sido muy
estudiadas en cambio los países del sur
donde ven ahí por ejemplo un rojo
intenso es donde hay mayor biodiversidad
vegetal y esa biodiversidad vegetal está
poco estudiada entonces las
posibilidades de generar nuevos
productos con valor agregado a partir de
esa biodiversidad vegetal son grandes
son muy grandes además como les decía
utilizamos mucho las plantas como
medicamentos
la mayor parte de la gente sabe cómo
utilizarlas y no son solamente plantas
que las conocen a nivel mundial como la
manzanilla sino a plantas nativas de
aquí como la chilca
en realidad hay mucha gente que sabe
cómo utilizarla entonces es un
conocimiento popular que es muy
importante rescatarlo y a partir de eso
hacer muchos estudios
por otra parte a nivel mundial se genera
billones de dólares a partir de
productos naturales botánicos en
alimentos en productos farmacéuticos y
en cosmética millones de dólares pero
para entrar a este mercado se necesita
toda una serie de estudios que
verifiquen la calidad seguridad y
eficacia del producto
porque esos productos naturales en el
mercado tienen tanto éxito en general
porque la gente tiene más confianza de
utilizar estos productos y no los
sintéticos porque porque muchas drogas
te hacen bien una cosa y te hace mal la
otra tiene muchos efectos colaterales en
cambio los productos naturales
normalmente no tienen muchos efectos
colaterales uno tiene más seguridad
cuando utilice eso y eso es porque
porque es una mezcla como les decía de
compuestos y la dosis de cada uno de los
compuestos es pequeña
entonces no llega a ser tóxica por eso
la gente prefiere utilizar esto y hay un
gran mercado en esto
además en realidad el desarrollo de un
producto fitoterápico requiere menos
tiempo muchísimo menos tiempo bueno en
realidad si se desarrolla un producto
normalmente 15 años del producto
fitoterápico normalmente necesita 5
aunque 5 años no es tan poco
requiere menos inversión los productos
ya les decía los normales
los farmacéuticos normales requieren
como miles de millones de dólares
nosotros pues requerimos más o menos 5
millones de dólares tampoco es poco pero
es factible es posible a este campo si
podemos ingresar
además con el respaldo de la medicina
tradicional el producto puede salir más
rápido al mercado por qué porque si no
una planta se utiliza por miles de años
en algo es porque no es tóxica ya
hubiera matado a gente de hecho entonces
no es tóxica eso es importantísimo lo
primero que tienes que probar para poner
un producto en el mercado es que no es
tóxica porque si no te hace bien no te
tiene que matar no es básico
hemos tomado
la base de empresas famosas en el mundo
como hacen las cosas las cosas para
hacerlas bien hay que pensar en cada uno
de los pasos y certificar una calidad en
cada uno de los pasos en la materia
prima en la planta en sí misma en el
extracto que es el principio activo del
producto y en el producto con valor
agregado que puede ser una crema un
jarabe no lo sé pero todo en cada uno de
los pasos tiene que haber una
verificación de la calidad seguridad y
eficacia y para eso se necesita formar
un equipo
nunca solos hay que buscar con quién
trabajar cada uno tiene que hacer lo que
tiene que hacer lo que sabe hacer bien
entonces nosotros más fuera un equipo
donde había químicos biólogos
bioquímicos farmacéuticos médicos y ahí
estamos que estos base ahí están por
detrás muchos estudiantes técnicos es es
un equipo grande pero además este equipo
es solamente parte de un ciclo
productivo porque para el desarrollo del
producto hay un ciclo de investigación
desarrollo e innovación ahí estamos
nosotros los científicos que tienen que
coordinar con él
ciclo de producción primaria
si algo se va a desarrollar tiene que
tener un desarrollo sostenible las
plantas tienen que tener un desarrollo
sostenible no podemos eliminar algunas
plantas de la tierra o sea no en
realidad ahí tenemos que trabajar y
hemos tenido que entablar colaboración
con comunidades que quieran producir esa
planta y por otro lado también está el
ciclo de transformación y mercadeo ahí
hemos tenido que establecer una
colaboración con una empresa
farmacéutica local interesada en esto y
al final lo hemos conseguido pero cada
una de estas colaboraciones es
complicado de establecerla pero si
funciona bien pues adelante
luego hemos elegido qué planta hay
muchas plantas muchísimos cada vez que
yo presento esto me dice yo conozco una
planta que funciona muy bien pero está
perfecto pues adelante hay que empezar
con esa planta pero cada estudio tarda
como cinco años mínimamente y cinco
millones de dólares o sea que hay que
pensar bien en que no ve y la planta que
nosotros hemos elegido se llama chilca
porque porque la el conocimiento que
tienen comunidades muy diversas es el
mismo se siembra la utilizan como
anti-inflamatoria como la vena y en
cataplasmas cuando se fracturan etcétera
y eso está relacionado a su composición
química tiene unos compuestos que ya
tienen un reconocido uso como
antiinflamatorios entonces había una
coordinación perfecta como para empezar
nuestros estudios y así pues con se hace
toda una serie de estudios largos
botánicos
químicos luego farmacológicos para
determinar toxicidad eficacia luego todo
un extracto controlado verificada su
eficacia toda eso pasa a la empresa
farmacéutica se elabora los productos y
el producto otra vez tiene que ser
evaluado en diferentes concentraciones
todo es un camino largo pero al final el
resultado exitoso y hemos tenido un
producto
que ha podido ser registrado el 2012 en
base a toda una serie de estudios que se
han publicado en un libro
este producto ha sido registrado en la
dirección nacional de medicamentos como
medicamento o sea como para entrar a la
farmacia como medicamento
eso estaba fantástico entonces ya
podíamos al día siguiente ponerlo en
farmacias que tenía el registro sin
embargo en todo esto nos hemos olvidado
que hay otra serie de cosas que tenemos
que tener cuidado en realidad el
producto ha llegado a farmacias el año
2016 porque por problemas económicos de
cómo se dividen utilidades y cosas por
el estilo y problemas
jurídicos en realidad o sea de quién a
quién pertenece cada cosa o sea patentes
y cosas así en realidad nosotros no
podemos sacar una patente porque todos
lo hemos publicado
si es públicas ya no puede sacar una
patente pero ojo en todo esto hemos
aprendido un montón y entre las cosas
que hemos aprendido es que también en el
grupo debería haber un economista un
abogado o sea mi grupo multidisciplinar
había era muy científico o sea
necesitaba de otras áreas sociales
económicas todo eso o sea es necesario
es más abierto pero hemos aprendido y a
mí particularmente me gusta decir que la
farmacia hay un producto que lo hemos
desarrollado en base a una planta
boliviana con un equipo boliviano con
una empresa farmacéutica local y eso es
es importante entonces se puede se puede
o sea con la colaboración de todos se
puede desarrollar y ahora tenemos nuevas
ideas para desarrollar otras cosas y
teniendo cuidado nosotros también
es un equipo estas partes del equipo
pero la idea es esa o sea vamos adelante
aprendemos y seguimos y si se fuerte
gracias
[Aplausos]